pensemos cuánto es 76 y los anima que
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolver
ustedes solos bueno asumo que hicieron
el intento podemos ver esto como siete
objetos más seis objetos y luego pensar
cuántos objetos tenemos en total
podríamos pensar en siete tomates un
tomate dos tomates tres tomates cuatro
tomates cinco seis y siete tomates y
después vamos a poner moras azules en
realidad lo que nos interesa es el
número total de frutas que tenemos 1 2 3
4 5 y 6 moras azules ahora lo que me
interesa saber es cuántas piezas de
fruta tengo empecé con 7 y sigo contando
esta es la fruta 8 9 10 11 12 y 13 ahora
tengo un total de 13 piezas de fruta
ok otra manera de pensar en esto es
usando una recta numérica vamos a
dibujar una recta numérica aquí abajo
aquí está nuestra recta numérica
aquí tenemos el 7 podemos empezar con el
7 aquí y vamos a sumar 6 vamos a avanzar
6 lugares en la recta numérica
2 3 4 5 6 y podríamos seguir marcando
más lugares
este es 8 9 10 11 12 y 13 podríamos
seguir anotando más números pero vamos a
visualizar 7 6 empezando en 7 y haciendo
seis saltos en la recta numérica un
salto 2 3 4 5 6
y de esta manera también llegamos a 13
otra manera de pensar en esto es
completando 10
empezamos en 7 y le sumamos 3 para
completar 10 y tenemos que sumar otros 3
lo que nos da 13 y lo que debemos
entender realmente es lo que el número 3
se representa el número 13 tiene un 1
del lado izquierdo en la posición de las
decenas que representa literalmente una
decena una decena 10 objetos más 3
unidades 3 unidades y lo podemos ver
aquí con el total de las frutas esto que
tenemos aquí es una decena de frutas una
decena de frutas son 10 frutas y tenemos
que sumar 3 frutas más a este grupo de
10 entonces después de llenar este
bloque de 10 frutas aquí tenemos otras 3
así que cuando sumamos 7-6 primero
completamos un grupo de 10 y luego
tenemos tres unidades más aquí están las
3 unidades más
entonces otra manera de pensar en sí
6 es 10 3 que por supuesto es igual a 13
una decena es 10 más 3 unidades es igual
a 13